you know all that other stuff but you
don't know his name
man
people tell me [__]
what's wrong with you
man
good night bob
goodnight golden jet
[Music]
how do you know the
my mother was an egyptologist
[__] [__]
just is she even in shock
[Laughter]
[Music]
who's your
friend lemnon sorcerer great guts she's
the sorcerer
wait a minute where are you going oh
hold on my daddy once cut catch a bullet
caught caught your bullet koch
my daddy want to cut a bullet by his
bare hand
no [__]
[Laughter]
yo yo george what's up with your family
with the tightest rap game on the street
what's good with you baby what's good
with you b it was really good baby huh
what's good with you man
you want to get dinner tomorrow night
late you're going to stay late well it's
always for you it is isn't it i'll have
dinner with you though should we yeah
can you get me laid
can you whistle no
uh make hand puppets out
i i once had a girl
who oh [__] that [__] life
i once knew
no i once had a girl
a good guy
i once had a girl
will i see you again only if you make it
and i guess i gotta make it
what the hell was that
do we have i need to print that i need
you but i need to see it let's catch
what was that cut what that's called
it's called misdirection
so don't stare at him whatever you do
you think you think uh mr t and and
sting and and the rock you think those
guys are real that's a bunch of dumbass
nicknames by a bunch of dumbass people
i guess i don't need speed no i'm not
gonna need that when i'm getting chased
by an enormous killer zebra or some
out here in the land of the goddamn loss
our tops
susan
[Applause]
see
these
[Laughter]
i nuts back in the water because you
thought i was dead i left my phone in
there so this whole time you had a cell
phone yes
i know it creates extraordinary logic
problems for the film
[Laughter]
news
susan
are you okay
okay just really give it a good
[Music]
i just want to say that
i greatly admire your excuses
here we go
and
man you got to be kidding me you're
going to pull out a gun when you looking
at this huh get out baby i didn't i
didn't know it was this much of a height
difference thank you you just check his
taint for needle monster
it's brown in the in the pubic hair
that's [__] check the tank always poop
for sure
smile
posted that please don't post that half
the internet or do you think i'm gay
yeah that's right i can't wait to
to join the gang can't wait to give the
beast a nice little belly rub it's gonna
be great yeah i can't wait to move in
who doesn't love rich mahogany seriously
it's called the x-men i mean there are
women here right it's very sexist i put
my hands on your [__] ty
yeah
okay see see now
let's [__] go
on delay on delay you big silver sex toy
you tampon chewing glistening communist
[__] let's go
dr phil can wait you can watch the
matthew mcconaughey lincoln commercials
later you communist [__] jim get out of
the car
jim get out of the car
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Laughter]
news
new
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
if i was a boxer i would
bounce those things like sugar ray
leonard
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
she
see how difficult is that my english he
even cannot see three words stare into
my soul
and i'll stare into yours command you
are not my wife hey
oh that's it
i promise
that's it
i can't do this
oh my god
screw it
i couldn't catch her
i ran and i ran and i ran you tried ah
[Music]
let's get in the fountain right now all
my jokes go ahead you clean me
clean me in the fountain right now give
you a little slash
50 million dollars so you think you got
kelsey clinton
kelsey
what's left 50 million dollars so you
think you got chelsea it's a chelsea cup
house 50 million dollars so you think
you got chelsea carter
[Applause]
50 million dollars who you think you got
chelsea grandma chelsea do you think you
got chelsea
50 million dollars so you think you got
chelsea clinton
keep him talking
not for nothing but you and i have a
very similar taste in pornography dude
it's like spooky similar for example
we're both in the milfs but then again
we're really into guilts what [__]
for example we're both into furries
we're both into clowns who knew for
example we're both bottoms you know what
i'm saying
what the [__] does that mean crap
they took off on us
what
one more one you'll be a light bulb
[Music]
dude you're on your own
[Laughter]